[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I
remember it so you don't have to well
this is embarrassing
the Nostalgia Critic on the nerd DVD
you're probably wondering what the hell
I'm doing here well you see we had a
little bed a while ago I bet that the
nerd would be able to make his gigantic
Oh piss Letta won't get it on DVD or
show it in a bunch of theatres to tons
of people obviously I've lost so he gave
me one of two options either do a review
of the movie or be whipped like a horse
pulling him down the streets of Chicago
with a sign on B saying I'm a fatty
fatty fuck fuck it was a tough call
let's get this over with
[Music]
remember that bunch of kids in high
school who said they wanted to make
movies remember how they used to show
you all their films they worked so hard
on
remember how no matter what you are
always so impressed with how they put
all their passion and all their love
into every single frame they shot and
despite all the dedication that they put
it to every single frame did you just
hate those fucking films the lame
effects the hokey acting the stories
that made no sense whatsoever well the
world loves to reward the insane and
this is the fruit of their labor hey you
paid for it so it only makes sense that
you should pay for it second let's take
a look at it we start off with a back
story about the world's most hated video
game spin-off which is in no way related
to the world's actual most hated video
games we swear this is when they
produced a game based on
highest-grossing film of that year
Steven Spielberg's et the end result was
a strange and incoherent game that
alienated devoted gamers well no wonder
they couldn't even get the characters
color writers fellows name correctly buy
a game based off of such a reputation
even though the new version will be
better it won't be better will make it
even worse
research shows gamers these days are
playing games they hate they think bad
is the new good consequently will cut
our expenses and double our profits an
Internet critics will make thousands
offer them to dance puppets dad you
monsters but how will they convince
people to play it all by using needless
profanities Holy Grail as a montage
happens showing all of his fans praising
the Nerds work it cost a t-shirt right
here who else can you think of that
actually cuddles up with the AVGN plush
dog got a angry
in their tattoos and got that
immortalized in ink that's nothing take
a look at the fan videos I get all the
time hey critic fight with a nerd we're
all angry at originally but it turns out
the nerd has a real life yeah we do
expect that from someone whose legal
name is apparently nerd he works at a
videogame store has an angry boss who
yells at him he even has a quirky black
sidekick you gotta make some unique
sacrifices no physical fitness no social
popularity no bad green screening no
claiming you're filming this for an
album that confusingly makes no sense
I almost gonna be good and most
importantly no starring in early 2006
comes our direct the DVD Disney sequels
the exploiting of IMDB must flow but
sure enough a lot of cameos come into
the store requesting the nerd review the
original et or as I should pronounce it
ete you know what I heard that Atari
recall all the cartridges no no I
already have a quirky black sidekick
call me if you can get me a ninja turtle
preferably one that's been in the Brady
Bunch
it must flow but already from Cockburn
Inc yeah that's really bad comes in to
tell him about their plan to review ete
he doesn't take it well oh my god I've
never seen so much green vomit come out
of one person's hand only sent that one
time yeah that was weird
he obviously says no but has a dream
that night to help improve trailer
father-like look zombies look there's
zombies in the movie everybody you like
zombies right the nerd fight zombies we
can put down the poster somewhere
I do realize that bear McQueary who did
the music didn't use the walking dead
theme for a scene that had zombies but
at least he played a zombie in there
does that count no it doesn't I want an
apology mr. query it's C minor I don't
think you meant it we're gonna find that
landfill and prove that there's nothing
under there so he agrees that did they
do find any games under there he'd
review them but Cooper says they need
proper equipment which brings in the
representative named Andy back unto the
sea yeah everything all right over there
the fans need you more than ever heard
so the world trip is on as Mandy keeps
her team updated on her progress
don't get too close to these nerds they
are the product don't worry mr. Cockburn
they're just a couple of dorks and I'm
not just saying that to reinforce the
irony that they're going to win me over
with their charm because as this movie
is clearly shown they have not
that's gonna turn to Huntress Thompson
by the time the movies over we were
somewhere in New Mexico the middle of
the desert when the dumb began to take
hold but evil evilness is keeping a
close eye on them as they're apparently
getting too close to their secret
operation this good Ward he's harnessing
the power of Mattel Missile Command
[Music]
thank Jesus we almost lost an entire
Tomeo to one of those terrorists alien
hunters as they send out a crew to
investigate team exposition discusses a
mythical creature so strange and so not
having anything to do with what's going
on at the moment Santa Claus is real
cyber mutant death God living under
Mount Fuji
he created come on I can't see anything
pressure for shadowing and thus we have
our monster so grand and so terrifying
that you'll be yelling all throughout
the film how do you say his name again
get lost six death wasps six
death wall six death mom sick get lost
six big moth sex yes Worf six so be
ready coming to destroy your city asleep
marketing must have love to you with a
single turn of the satellite dish on top
of his head
every universe in the multiverse will
disappear non-existence no space nothing
nope well one thing will remain a
bologna sandwich you might ask because
Bologna needs a funny worked he could
have just as easily said cabbage banana
or Lake Titicaca none of it would have
changed the story oh banana might blood
help for the sake of cannon and to
keeping the theme of the movie the
reason only a bologna sandwich would be
left in the universe is Chaka poison I
don't know what it is but hey if they
can make up a story for 10 min I'm sure
I can make up one for that too
but the military comes into a resting
for most of the movie wet that's the
line most uttered on the set are you
sure they didn't just forget to turn the
camera off during certain scenes hands
on the vehicle right you don't get your
panties in a wad I'm not wearing any
panties well I'm sure you just made a
perverted little five-year-old boys
sexual fantasy come true but the general
accidentally blows up his arm just a
flesh wound and they escaped through a
car chase
food dishes the size of those melons
take a note mcbutter well I'm sure you
just made a perverted little
four-year-old boy sexual fantasy come
true they outrun them and decide to go
searching for the person who designed
the original game but they find the
place is full of poorly rendered booby
traps hey as long as it's not as far as
the original Japanese and we're brothers
too
you'll be all right they don't fund the
creator per se but a man named mr. Zand
or a scientist who used to work at area
51 did you know the Atari logo was based
off Mount Fuji I was found out all day
well how may I help you god this
foreshadowing is just as well woven in
as a basket with two holes in it and
that sucker crashed in the desert and
broke up like one of those clay pigeons
in duck hunt there was me telling debris
all over the desert or Deborah's no it's
debris oh there's an S why is it Browns
Deborah's I don't know how come you
always say Barry instead of Barry we
need to buried in the past where it
belongs what our he explains how an
alien ship did crash into area 51 and
that the secret to how to get inside is
hidden within unity on top of that and
innocent alien life is still kept in
captivity oh we have an alien out too
huh jeez don't people ever get bored of
all this area 51 nonsense yeah hard to
believe seeing how the nerd hasn't come
across any strange aliens or monsters in
the past for now make yourselves at home
there are video games upstairs so the
team just sort of takes it easy for a
bit I guess I suppose if I found out
aliens were real I just play on the
Power Pad or reflect filming lights off
of my glasses to amateurs but when
trying to get a better reception maybe
gets caught but promises to take them to
Xander's house of course leading them to
all the funniest places they could take
pictures of and green screen and later
we have to ditch you I thought she's a
gamer
girl she's not a game these are phony
prescription glasses with fake plastic
lenses it was all an act don't you
understand she's bait why would she do
this to appear more nerdy by God the
really are fake gamer girls every
internet troll who's never had sex
before he's right congratulation
but word gets around about the Nerds
journey and people form a huge gathering
around the landfill populated by all the
leftover cameos that couldn't be fit in
anywhere else when the nerd tries to
tell them it's all bullshit lo and
behold the designer of ute himself comes
in Howard Scott Warshaw I've seen your
videos I know you are a frank and honest
man people like us we don't cover things
up wouldn't this be a better world if
people told the truth if a lot of people
learn to tell the truth the world would
be a better place to live the truth now
that is what you must find
there goes the best and yet somehow
worst video game designer of all time
he'll most likely get a job at EA Games
but the Nerds still thinks he can debunk
the myth so he gets dressed up in worse
effects than well the movies I guess M
edges to not so subtly sneak his way I
[Music]
fall it's my thing sure enough the
inside looks just like the video game
and he gets himself caught so let's
reveal that Zander replaced all the
space metal with tin foil because of
this the general decides to blow up
Mount Fuji I'm surprised you don't see
the connection there don't you know that
duct tape cardboard doors lightly pushed
together are the strongest things in the
world
damn follow but it looks like the alien
escapes and helps the nerd do so as well
I thought you were just a hoax yeah we
get a lot of that around here clearly
it's raised too so advanced that their
mouths don't even have to close to form
audible words sure enough to look good
is finally released
looking as evil as a ceramic Tim Curry
fucking a ceramic dr. octopus
you know can you imagine actually asking
for a tank in this shoot no really we
just want to tell a story about a video
game puppet who has to stop a bigger
video game puppet all coming from an
internet series I shot in my basement
for no well I'll have our ladies hitting
each other okay so why is around the
globe destroying the earth or practices
destroying the place eyes muddled verb
before actually destroying the real
thing
god I see more carnage out of a toddler
destroying his Happy Meal toy in fact be
sure that's not what I'm watching
but mcbutter agrees to challenge Mandy
to a fight because again they had to get
that ting somehow and they partake in
chicken chick martial arts now I thought
I could get through this without
objectifying myself in a sexy catfight
but it looks like that's impossible now
just because you say you're doing it
doesn't make it any better
I almost hurt my manicure but the alien
calls all the video game cartridges to
him to rebuild his ship this leads to
easily hands-down the best performance
in the entire movie
[Music]
look at the beer in his eyes look at the
depth he's portraying look at how many
emotions this actor is able to get
across in just a couple of seconds he
may have only had one moment of screen
time but he changed cinema with it done
deed may be defeats mcbutter only to be
captured again but it's okay
Cooper helped save the nerd only to be
captured again God you could just call
this film getting captured the movie
there's more people being bound up in
this film that Fifty Shades of Grey
ah Mandy looks so adorably plans pick
while screaming in distress but sure
enough the nerd comes to save the day
nyan catches Cooper and Mandy they tried
to destroy the satellite at Smith head
which ultimately results in this brought
to you by the miracle of randomness like
the saying goes if you don't get it
Kaka boys there I finally point to some
good news for at least better use than
the bologna sandwich seriously what was
that again
and of course having saved the day Mandy
gets together with her obvious love
interest in the movie Cooper because
clearly they were setting that up hey I
guess if you can survive being a metal
tentacle hand tie you can pretty much
bond over anything and as you'd expect
the ending credits is a review of the
game which even then isn't really as
major as you'd expect so is it really
the worst game of all time
I don't think so it's frustrating it's
challenging and it's a brain teaser but
that's what makes it so addicting and
considering it was made in such a short
period of time it's more sophisticated
than anything of its era is the greatest
bad game of all time reviewed by the
greatest video game critic of all time
and the final epic conclusion is
actually to the nerds credit that's the
only reaction he could give that
wouldn't be obvious if he screamed and
yelled and took a shit on and we'd all
know and becoming but a reaction like
that is kind of unexpectedly refreshing
hell he might even get a lot of people
to kind of agree with him on it
canal boy I could get that same about
people to agree with me
[Applause]
and remember forgiveness is divine but
never pay full price for a pizza and
that's the movie and it's your movie
everything you wanted to see is here the
review of the game the nerd being the
nerd effects fake but impressively
practical the homage to millions of
geeky films from Godzilla it's a fucking
Ninja Turtles 3 you've pretty much got
exactly what was to be expected but that
doesn't mean I like it just means I
don't not not not like it but with that
said everyone has been asking me after
this movie came out nostalgia critic are
you ever gonna do a movie are you ever
gonna do a film that's gonna be released
in theatres and all that bullshit well
there's another reason that I did this
review for this DVD yeah that's right
right here right now on the nerds turf I
am happy to announce that I the
nostalgia critic and going to release an
official nostalgia critic
oops
[Music]
you
did you see that